in order to build deep neural networks
one modification to the basic
convolutional operation that you need to
really use is padding let's see how it
works what we saw in earlier videos is
that if you take a 6x6 image and
convolve it with a 3x3 filter you end up
with a 4x4 output with a 4x4 matrix and
that's because the number of possible
positions for your 3x3 filter they're
only sort of four by four possible
positions for the 3x3 filter to fit in
your 6x6 matrix and the math for this
turns out to be that if you have a n by
n image and to involve that with an FF
filter then the dimension of the output
will be n minus F plus 1 by n minus F
plus 1 and in this example 6 minus 3
plus 1 is equal to 4 which is why you
want up with a 4 by 4 output so the two
downsides to this one is that if every
time you apply a convolutional operator
your image shrink so we've gone from 6
by 6 down to 4 by 4 then you know you
can only do this a few times before your
image starts getting really small maybe
it strings down to one by one or
something so maybe you don't want your
image to shrink every time you two
changes or to other features on it so
that's one downside and the second
downside is that if you look at the
pixel at the corner of the page this
little pixel is touchless used only in
one of the outputs because it touches
that feed by the region whereas if you
take a pixel in the middle say this
pixel then there are lot of feed by
three regions that overlap that pixel
and so it's as if pixels on the corners
around the edges are used much less in
the output so you're throwing away a lot
of the information near the edge of the
image so to solve both of these problems
you know both the shrinking output
and when we put really deep neural
networks you see why you don't want the
image to shrink on every step because if
you have maybe a hundred layer deep net
then if it strings a bit on every layer
then after 100 years you end up with a
very small image so that was one problem
the other is you know throwing away of
all of the information from the edges of
the image so in order to fix both of
these problems what you can do is before
applying the convolutional operation you
can add the image so in this case let's
say you pad the image with an additional
one border with an additional border of
one pixel or around the edges so if you
do that then instead of a six by six
image you've now padded this to an 8 by
8 image and if you convolve an eight by
eight image of a three by three image
you now get back out now the four by
four by the six by six image and so
you've managed to preserve the original
input size of six point six so by
convention when you've had you padded
with zeros and if P is the padding
amount so in this case P is equal to one
because we're padding all around with an
extra border of one pixels then the
output becomes n might and plus 2p minus
f plus 1 by n plus 2p minus F by one so
this becomes 6 plus 2 times 1 minus 3
plus 1 by the same thing and that so 6
plus 2 minus 3 plus 1 that's equal to 6
so you end up with a six by six image
that's preserving the size of the
Arsenal input so this being pixel
actually influences all of these cells
of the output and so this effect
you know maybe not quite thering away
but counting less the information from
the edge of a corner or the edge of the
image is reduced and I've shown here the
effect of having the border with just
one pixel if you want you can also pad
the border with two pixels in which case
I guess you know add on another border
here and that you can pattern with even
more pixels if you choose so I guess
what I'm drawing here this would be a
pad of equal to or equals to in terms of
how much to pad it turns out there are
two common choices that are called
valid convolutions and saying
convolutions not sure these are great
names but in a valid convolution this
basically means no padding and so in
this case you might have an N by n image
convolve moving F by F filter and this
will give you an N minus F plus 1 by n
minus F plus 1 dimensional output so
this is a like the example we had
previously from the previous videos
where we had an N by n image to involve
with a 3 by 3 filter and that gave you a
4 by 4 output the other most common
choice of padding is called the same
convolution and that means when you pad
so the output size is the same as the
input size so if we actually look at
this formula when you pad by P pixels
then this as if n goes to n plus 2 P and
then you have a from the rest of this
right minus F plus 1 so we have an N by
n image and the padding of a border of P
pick holes all around then the output
size ends up being this dimension n plus
2 P minus F plus 1 and so
if you want n plus 2p minus f plus 1 to
be equal to one so that the output size
is the same as the input size if you
take this and solve for I guess n
cancels out on both sides and if you
solve for P this implies that P is equal
to F minus 1 over 2 so when F is odd by
choosing the padding size to be as
follows you can make sure that the upper
size is the same as the input size and
that's why for example when the filter
was 3 by 3 as in the example on the
previous slide the padding that would
make the upper size the same as the
input size was V minus 1 over 2 which is
1 and as another example if your filter
was 5 by 5 so if F is equal to 5 then if
you plug it into that equation you find
it a padding of 2 is required to keep
the output size the same as the input
size when when the filter is 5 by 5 and
by convention in computer vision F is
usually odd is that he almost always odd
and you rarely see even number filters
filter webs using computer vision and I
think the two reasons for that
one is that if F was even you know then
you need some a summation adding it's
only if F isn't that this type of same
convolution use the natural padding we
can add the same dimension all around
other than you know had more on the left
and pad less on the right or something
asymmetric and then second when you have
an odd dimension filter such as 3 by 3
or 5 by 5 then it has a central position
and sometimes in computer vision is nice
to have a
distinguished it's nice to have a pixel
you can call the central pixel so you
can talk about you know the position of
the filter maybe none of these is a
great reason for using f to be pretty
much always odds that you look the
communication literature you see 3x3
filters are very common you see some 5x5
seven by sevens you know and actually
sometimes well later we'll also talk
about one-by-one filters and when that
makes sense but just by convention I
recommend you just use odd numbered
filters as well I think that you can
probably get just fine performance even
if you were to use an even number value
for F but if you stick to the common
computer vision convention you know I
usually just use odd-numbered F so
you've now seen how to use pattern
convolutions to specify the padding for
a convolutional operation you can either
specify the value for P or you can just
say that this is a valid convolution
which means P equals zero or you can say
this is a same convolution which means
add as much as you need to make sure
that the output has the same dimension
as the input so that's it for padding in
the next video let's talk about how you
can implement strided convolutions